dr arruda qui vous répondais dr weiss
bonsoir dr weiss au sort alors vous avez
signé avec plusieurs autres médecins
spécialistes une lettre demandant au
gouvernement de rendre obligatoire le
masque vous venez d'entendre docteur
arruda qui dit pour l'instant on préfère
attendre vous d'abord pourquoi vous
croyez qu'ils iront au doigt le rendent
obligatoire est votre réaction suite à
la réponse
écoutez là pour qu'on doit le rendre
obligatoire d'abord parce que c'est la
seule mesure qui actuellement a été
démontré comme étant la plus efficace
pour réduire la transmission d'un virus
qui se transmet principalement par les
voies respiratoires
donc on parle du lavage des mains bien
sûr on encourage de la mhd n'améliore
qu'une étude qui montre que le lavage
des mains à une quelconque efficacité
pour réduire la transmission de la cobac
19 c'est très bon pour le clostridium
difficile c'est très bon pour des virus
de gastro entérite on le sait mais pour
celui là en particulier
ça fait partie des mesures générales
mais aucune étude ne la lève le masque
par contre il ya à peu près cent
vingt-huit pays qui ont instauré le
masque de façon obligatoire
la majorité de ces pays l'an pour
beaucoup ont bien maîtrisé il y en a
quand même en très bien maîtriser
l'épidémie ce qui est très loin d'être
le cas au québec puisque on est
actuellement il faut faire le bilan un
peu de la première vague on est
littéralement quasiment les pires dans
le monde occidental où certainement
parmi les 2,3 pire alors il faut
certainement se poser des questions sur
ce qu'on pourrait améliorer
alors comme on a pas de vaccin et on n'a
pas de médicaments qu'on pourra donner
en prophylaxie et qui a plusieurs études
qui recommande le port du masque
universel que beaucoup dans de
recommandations venant du cdc qui est
l'organisme américain très réputé et qui
a une qui est très crédible de le cbc
qui est le pendant américain met dehors
de la communauté européenne de l'union
européenne
d'autres organisations qui ont fait des
études comme les gens de l'université
hier des méta-analyses donc des études
qui ont été publiées dont une dans le 27
et même si on sait que le lynx est un
piètre controversé récemment cette étude
avait été très bien fait si on met tout
ça ensemble
je pense que vous savez on a le
feu dans la maison et on se demande
encore s'il faut appeler les pompiers
alors je pense que si on veut continuer
un déconfinement adéquat il va falloir
porter un masque
alors tentons d'y obligatoire ça veut
dire qu'il faut que ce soit très
fortement encouragé la santé publique
joue sur les mots depuis longtemps au
québec on voit qu actuellement ça n'a
pas changé grand chose malheureusement
sur le nombre de décès on a vu l'écart
diminuer principalement due à d'autres
facteurs entre autres le confinement
laon bat est confiné on a vu des pays
qui ont réussi beaucoup mieux que ce
qu'on a fait qui dès qu'ils étaient
confinés ont commencé à voir une
augmentation du nombre de cas et ces
pays ont déjà institué depuis très
longtemps le port du masque universel
donc faudrait pas que ça devienne un
port je dirais policiers du masque dans
le sens que si vous ne portez pas votre
masque on va vous arrêter ou vous mettre
une amende mais je pense qu'il va
falloir se soit fait de façon
intelligente de favoriser le port
universel du mas d'expliquer aux gens et
puis même au contraire je pense que même
la police qui d'ailleurs beaucoup
travailler quand premiers répondants
vous savez les policiers ont fait partie
du travail qui a été fait durant cette
première vague pourrait même distribué
les masques plutôt que de donner des
amendes ou quoi que ce soit tandis que
jeudi hong kong et quand je dis
obligatoires il faut comprendre que ça
devra passer surtout pas dans un
contexte policier si vous n'avez pas
votre masque on va vous arrêter ou
donner une amende au contraire je
pensais plutôt dans un contexte
d'explication à la population générale
que là on veut plus retourner en
confinement
on veut plus retourner où on est et on
veut profiter de la réouverture de la
vie normale off et donc le masque et
toutes façons de réduire
considérablement la transmission comme
alors on se pose des questions au québec
où les réponses des autres existe depuis
déjà très longtemps entre autoroute on
qui va compter du 8 juillet dans les
transports en commun le rendu
obligatoire paris s'est fait depuis
longtemps new york aussi mais je reviens
sur quelque chose vous avez dit dr weiss
avait dit on est parmi les pires
sur la planète est ce que notre lourd
bil'in et
les lourds au québec n'est pas presque
entièrement expliquée par la situation
dans les résidences pour personnes âgées
mais vous avez apprécié de l'expliquer
par tout ce qu'on veut il n'empêche que
malheureusement il ya aussi des gens qui
sont décédés qui n'étaient pas des
personnes âgées
et oui les personnes âgées ont
malheureusement a été un très gros poids
mais il faut pas oublier non plus qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ne sont pas
décédées il ya eu cinq ans plus de 50
mille cas au québec qui sont toujours
vivantes aujourd'hui mais qui ont
beaucoup de mal à s'en sortir qui ont
besoin de soins de réhabilitation nous
ne sont pas retournés à l'heure et après
covin donc ces gens là sont pas
comptabilisées si vous voulez dans les
problèmes secondaires à la colline mais
il existe bien alors cinquante mille cas
au québec plus de 50000 15 si on se
prend pas par exemple à la colombie
britannique alberta et même à l'ontario
dont on a des provinces canadiennes on
vit dans le même pays on a des systèmes
de santé qui sont similaires qui ceux
qui ceux qui se ressemblent beaucoup
avec un accès qui est pareil je
comprends que des différences avec les
états unis pas beaucoup mais y en a il
ya quelques différences avec les pays
européens n'est pas beaucoup mais y en a
mais finalement on a à peu près le même
bilan que la suède avec une population
similaire mais qui a été qui a fait
beaucoup moins de confinement que nous
donc s'ils ont la peau critiquer le
modèle suédois
ce qui est vrai les suédois comparé au
norvégien ou danois ont très mal fait
mais finalement nous on a aussi
magnifique les suédois mais en ayant
confinés comme les sardes et donc il
faut se poser la question de qu'est-ce
qui n'a pas fonctionné
je reviens sur les masses donc la
réponse docteur arruda ne vous satisfait
aucunement que c'est pas une question
qu'elle me satisfait qu'elle ne
satisfait pas je pense que l'idée c'est
d'exprimer son son opinion en regardant
ce qui a été publié dans la littérature
scientifique
en regardant ce qui a été fait dans des
pays qui ont très bien réussi
alors ce qu'il faut prendre exemple de
ce qui a été fait ailleurs surtout ceux
qui ont été des très bons élèves et se
dire s'ils l'ont fait il doit avoir
quelque chose qui fonctionne dans cet
aspect là donc c'est tout simplement de
prendre ce qui existe actuellement dans
la littérature
vous savez on encourage de lavage des
mains mais le lavage des mains il n'y a
aucune étude qui a démontré que c'était
efficace comme je vous ai dit pour
prévenir lakovic 19 la distanciation
social vous voyez bien que en europe on
parle d'un mètre en amérique du nord on
a dit de m aux états unis on discipline
qui peuvent te fais dr weill vous me
renverser
parce que le lavage des mains on en
parle depuis quoi 13 semaines ensemble
les gens nous sommes on a plus de
jointure tellement qu'on se lave les
mains et vous me dites là jour en jour
88 je sais pas vous mais que je lâche
des meilleurs rien qui nous montrent que
ça aide
non je vais préciser regardez il n'ya ou
le lavage des mains c'est très important
les gens ne doivent pas la rage des
masses est très important dans ce qu'on
appelle un ensemble de mesures comprend
et combien en place pour réduire les
infections de façon générale c'est ça
qu'il faut sortir mais pour la copie de
19 spécifiquement si vous avez le choix
entre la vie d'emma maîtres hamas y a
pas d'étude qui ont dit les 200
personnes qui se sont lavés
continuellement les mains et beaucoup
plus fréquemment il y en a pas beaucoup
qui ont attrapé la copie les deux sens
qui se sont pas lavés les mains d'un feu
ont attrapé la codi on sait que la
copine c'est pas une transmission par
contact direct ou indirect en maladies
infectieuses
je suis spécialiste en maladies
infectieuses on apprend ça très
rapidement le lavage des mains c'est
pour la transmission de maladies qui
sont surtout par contact direct ou
indirect
donc je touche des surfaces qui sont
contaminés et je me contamine à mon tour
donc par exemple la clusterine clu
clostridium difficile
le hervé ce qu'on appelait des bactéries
résistantes lavage des mains c'est
fondamental dans les hôpitaux c'est
extrêmement important
mais pour les infections respiratoires
le lavage des mains sales à rôle moins
important que le mars parce que
principalement la transmission se fait
par des gouttelettes donc si je vous
parle plus proche de vous je vous parle
je vous envoie des couplets dans la face
et si j'ai les microbes
vous risquez de les attraper alors ce
que je veux dire c'est que le lave on a
on a on n'encourage pas le mas mais
c'est pas juste moi qui le dit mais il
ya d'autres personnes qui
vous avez vu beaucoup de signataires et
des gens de milieux très différents et
donc et tout le monde y écouter le
lavage des mains il ya personne qui dit
qu'il faut arrêter de lavage des mains
c'est mais le problème c'est
qu'actuellement il n'y a pas de leiria
pas de données qui dit que le lavage des
mains c'est ce qui va réduire de façon
importante la pandémie de lakovic 19
transmises par des gouttelettes qui est
un virus respiratoires principalement
bien des données unis ce que le mas a
beaucoup plus d'efficacité et toutes les
données semblent concorder dans ce sens
là et 129 pays sur la planète donc
quasiment toute l'europe
je vous dirais beaucoup de pays du
moyen-orient plusieurs pays d'amérique
du sud
beaucoup de pays en asie ont institué le
port du masque universel bondée les pays
qui ont le mieux fait on le mas
universel dr weiss on va se reparler on
ne prendra pas autant de tabous tant
qu'on ne s'était pas vrai on va faire
parler parce que je vous parlais des
tests sérologiques également
l'importance de sow mais là on a mis le
focus sur le masque et je crois que
c'est important de le faire merci
beaucoup aux docteurs m'ont fait plaisir
à voir et à revoir